this is evident Galen podcast it's the
best podcast for you and me maybe we
shouldn't try singing we need a good job
good job
Thanks
you know what words are hard you should
put that on a t-shirt all right guys
today we're gonna be talking about our
early lives we're gonna share some
awkward teenage years stories perhaps
Caitlyn is gonna continue quizzing me
about Pinterest yes and as usual we will
be sharing our things of the week at the
end of the show so super exciting thing
this podcast episode is sponsored do
this
so our sponsor this week is Squarespace
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business and we'll hear more
about them later yes we will
thank you Squarespace yeah yeah so this
topic was kind of your idea so I'm going
into it a little bit blind yeah so so I
I know my own childhood well you you
have a better memory than me so I had to
kind of like think back a little bit
actually because I'm just very forgetful
I just don't think backwards too much
yeah I actually wanted to cover this
topic because it led into a suggestion
that we got for a podcast episode on our
youtube channel did you know that on
youtube.com slash Evan katelyn podcast
you can leave suggestions on what
episodes you might want us to cover I
didn't know that but I'm so glad you
told me oh you're welcome you're welcome
thank you thank you
but we got questions about like our
hobbies games that influenced us movies
TV shows like what influenced us as we
grew up and stuff and I felt like before
we cover that we should kind of share
some of our backstory in a way I mean we
kind of covered the origin at evident
Caitlyn but we didn't really cover the
origin of evidence okay
so I thought that the awkward teenage
years would be a good a funny ripe area
for stories and everything but I tried
looking up questions for this to prepare
for this podcast interview and I found a
whole bunch of like really easy like
ways to talk about your childhood
questions to ask people about their
childhood like icebreaker type things it
was pretty easy to find a whole bunch of
those but as soon as you entered like
teenage or teenager or teenage years
everything got awkward no one wants to
talk about their teenage years well but
it was all about like parents like
advice to parents on how to talk to
their teenagers and everything like that
those was like a bajillion results about
like all of the awkward teenage years
and like how to talk to teens and
everything talk to your teenager it was
a lot of that so I didn't find too much
so I made some stuff up okay cool
but I thought that one thing that we
could share that some most people
probably don't know about us is that we
moved a whole bunch when we were growing
up we lived in seven different places
each yeah it was kind of weird so for me
it was New Mexico Texas Dubai California
two places in California Saudi Arabia
then Texas ever just read that list
because he had to write it down
yes few places in Tennessee Alabama
North Carolina Houston San Antonio
California back to Houston California is
only kinda halfway yeah but still that's
a lot of places and I think that kind of
shaped some of our childhood and and
like our personalities and stuff like
one of the things I was thinking about
is the pros and cons of moving around
that much yeah I mean it was something
that I definitely thought about a lot in
the moment too as I was experiencing it
but I do think there are significant
pros and cons I think so too I try to
focus more on the pros because that was
my life yeah it's like you don't really
get to negative about your own life yeah
but yeah I tried to look at the positive
see I mean I think the very first move
that I moved were like I had lived in a
place for six years the longest I had
lived in the place at that point and
when I moved away from there I was kind
of sad but I think I really did
appreciate it
kind of growing up because I think the
biggest thing for me is I always thought
a lot about my personality and who I
wanted to be and like what type of
person I wanted to be I thought about
that a strangely large amount for a kid
I think yeah maybe because I moved
around a lot and I was able to change a
lot it's kind of like starting a new
character like in the video game it's
like you got to start a new character
every like year or two yeah and you can
kind of like recreate yourself a little
bit which is weird to think of but also
really cool ya know I I do the same
thing I definitely took advantage of
that time when you're growing up in one
place forever
everyone knows every stage yeah you
can't break out of a mold that you are
in in a way you know yeah okay so what
were some of your phases that you went
through like some of the changes you
made I think that when I was growing up
I've always been fairly awkward
I've always been fairly nerdy and
reserved in some ways it's so funny you
say that because when we met in college
you were nerdy yes but you are not
awkward and you're not reserved I
thought I think maybe that's just how I
saw myself maybe outwards I presented
differently or something but also by the
time I got to college I'd had figured
myself out a little bit I had broken
free of some of those teenage year like
woes and I was fairly confident after
like kind of re-examining myself so many
times I was confident in like who I was
and who I wanted to be and I kind of
went into college because most people
wouldn't they go to college that's their
one chance to change you know like break
away from the friends they've known
their whole lives to some degree they go
to college and they kind of get a fresh
start in life or something you know yeah
that's true I mean if if they went to
college if they went to college there's
not that that chance yeah motto built in
I'm starting social situation yeah I go
through some phases there is definitely
like the most distinct phase is I went
through like a slight rebellious phase I
started
hanging out with a bad crowd how old
were you oh that was in seventh grade
1330 no that was 13 oh my gosh I was
such a little punk yeah are nothing
really bad but like what did you do
I might have vandalized something what
did you vandalize things oh you got tell
me I already told you I know you tell
people you can't bring this up and not
answer questions this is your right hand
it's so awkward
I was embarrassed knows it was like
someone else's property it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't a proud moment for me
and I very quickly learned from that it
was just like one experience I kind of
got wrapped up in something I did
something that I regretted I got caught
thankfully I paid the price I apologized
and I never did anything stupid like
that again so I'm kind of glad that like
I did something stupid I paid the price
and I was like why why did I do that
yeah yeah it was kind of a formative
experience I'd say it's interesting
thinking of you in like a like
rebellious bad group of kids but at the
same time the whole time I was also like
doing well in school and even the
rebellious kids like we were all like
still doing well in school and
everything and still being seriously
just bored outside of school yeah I
think that I don't know we were maybe
trying to I don't know I have no clue
like I'm so far removed from that point
in life I should have like written down
a diary I know you had a diary right it
did I didn't really have a diary hmm
yeah have you ever read your old Diaries
it's painful it's painful
I need someone the podcast I I went I
was a very emo key which is also funny
cuz like a lot has changed since then
yeah yeah I mean I guess like I don't
know I listened a lot of like My
Chemical Romance
and used and Panic at the Disco got
feelings and you felt them down no um
yeah
I don't know it is it is kind of
interesting that that one thing that I
did realize looking back trying to think
of questions to ask each other one thing
I realized is a common thing that I felt
a lot in those teenage years is I over
blue the importance of everything I over
blue the importance of grades I over
blue the importance of like a dance my
interaction with that person like this
is everything everything felt like so
life and not life and death but like or
maybe I just care about things less now
or something I don't know I guess when
you're that age it's hard to understand
the impact I mean at any age that is
younger than your current age it's hard
to understand the impact of the
situation you're in on the rest of your
life
it's the first time you're dealing with
that kind of situation and then it
happens again and again and you're like
oh it's no big deal yeah it's like even
the things that happen recently I feel
like it's that still happens sometimes
you know we like launch started first
we're Tube channels and we posted the
video without sound and I was like I
think that even by then we realize like
within an hour like I think I think that
is like a pretty common thing did you go
through a phase where you thought that
people didn't understand you really not
really cuz it was always still pretty
like I was awkward but I I was always
very close to my family
yeah I think that's part of you know
when you move a lot that's definitely
pro you know security comes your unit
you know and both of us had siblings
that we became really close with because
when you move a lot
you lose everyone but your family yeah
thank you
you're built in constant when your
family's your there your continual thing
throughout all the moves yes as I close
with my family so I didn't feel like no
one under I was like slightly angsty
sometimes but it was also like some of
the stuff that I dealt with was like
yeah big deal
yeah I agree like like you know like bad
experiences or bad experiences and
comparing them is very hard yeah it's
like it was a big deal for me at the
time yeah yeah you know yeah yeah I also
think that like I'm not sure how much I
felt this but I think that at some point
in everyone's life you might think that
someone doesn't understand you but at
the same time people do I don't know
looking back on it that's a very vague
statement I should maybe clarify some
it's also hard cuz I didn't really go
through that phase of feeling like
people didn't understand me mm-hm but I
also had like lots of outlets to express
myself complain I was close to my family
so I would like to talk to my family
yeah I drew a lot and I would post stuff
online and I could like express my
teenage angst through my art you know
what I mean like and yeah what that one
thing that the internet really has done
is that you know no one is really alone
anymore like you know like no matter
what unique scenario you're in you know
make a post on Reddit and someone will
find it and say that's me too it's kind
of crazy
yeah and and and not feeling alone going
through those experiences you know I
think it really helps yeah
I'm still being vague I don't really
have any specific examples I can pick up
for anything
insert reference to Evans bad memory
here so you know it's one interesting
thing huh as you know we were just
talking about moving a lot and I
realized that we've we've been in our
current house more than either of us
lived in any of our houses growing up
yeah and it's it's weird cuz like I
would have seemed like that I would have
thought that by now I'd really have like
the itch to get to a new place there are
some moves were like by the time we
moved I was kind of like yeah I'm ready
to move again yeah you know which is
kind of weird you know um cuz sometimes
it definitely was really hard I always
pictured myself continuing to move me
Tia you know I'm kind of like I mean we
do want a bigger place we talked about
in the episode where we talked about her
dream shop but really that's just the
only reason we want to move is for
business reasons and logistical reasons
I don't really feel the need to move
just to move yeah because I think that
you know I think that we have a lot of
freedom and flexibility to change mainly
because of this job that we've created
for ourselves yeah I think one of the
the cons looking back on kind of all the
moves that we did is it it is kind of
hard to create those like super lifelong
friends that you've always been with and
always been close with and and
everything and we have made lots of
really good friends but I always like
kind of thought growing up like I wonder
what to be like like I have known
someone since preschool and you're still
like friends with them forever and ever
it's like like another family member
basically that level of yeah like close
estimate I think we have a bunch of
cousins we all both have a lot of
cousins yeah yeah you've been in their
lives for so long yeah cuz I don't
really have any friends that I've known
since childhood that I was like I mean I
yeah yeah I mean with with Facebook I
actually rebound some friends from when
I when I was like three yeah fed up and
hung out and it was kind of just like
like we were you know we were picking up
this friendship that we dropped when we
were not writing so you do kind of like
I mean you weren't constantly internship
but you picked it back up yeah that's
cool that is really cool I have my only
friends from that young that I remember
the names of it's really generic names
and I've tried
look them up and I know that's crazy so
like one one question that I had is like
when you when you picture your childhood
now picture it visually like like a
photograph almost okay oh I'm gonna
picture a photograph I need like an age
range well you like your childhood like
for me oh I'll give an example for me
like my childhood is we were in Dubai
cuz that like that was different for you
because you lived in that place for from
longest and it was at an age where you
had memories your first few places you
don't remember at all but also it's
weird I think I've made I made the most
dense amount of amount of memories while
I was living in Dubai I kind of had a
really rich experience while I was there
and I think that I kind of like went
into myself I like this this sounds
kinda weird but like I like read a lot
of books I went like really nerdy with
PDA it's like you know they're like Palm
Pilots and stuff like that I completely
found my inner nerd and like there were
definitely like some years that when I
look back on them they're kind of bland
in though in a weird way you know like
the memories don't really stick with me
okay is that weird that is that the
answer to your what no no where I was
going with this is like so so my
childhood when I picture it in my head
so I have an older brother and a much
younger sister and it's like the the
whole family gathered together at
Christmas I'm in like a gigantic
oversized t-shirt it's like an alien
print because I this war have like a ton
I had a ton of gigantic oversized
t-shirts that all had aliens on t-shirts
they're all my dad's some of them were
glow-in-the-dark ooh
and one was like an alien license like
driver's license and one was just a big
old alien but like I'm in a giant
t-shirt I have an alien on it and we're
all gathered around like opening
Christmas presents that's like my
childhood in like one photo okay I have
two answers okay two answers because I
had
- like my two places that my formative
childhood years were that I have the
most memories of we're Alabama in North
Carolina okay so and they're kind of
similar memories hmm
sort of Alabama is just like because
where we lived there was all these crazy
like trees and woods and like my brother
and I and our friends in the
neighborhood would just explore them and
spend pretty much all day outside and we
would name different areas we had like
clay pond
we've glass mountain so dangerous we had
the jungle gym which is where there's
one tree on top of a little like not
cliff but you know place where the
ground dropped off in another Tran the
lower part and the roots from the upper
one wrapped around the branches of the
lower one and we would like to hang out
in the jungle gym with net so it's just
like hanging out outside a lot and then
the other is in North Carolina hanging
out outside a lot because there were
some really cool woods and my friends
and I would just roam around just hang
out the woods that's all we did like
some hooligans yeah bad we just like it
was more fun to hang out in the woods
and hang on in our driveways yeah it's
true that's interesting for me like a
lot of my like hanging out time was
spent out of pool because in Dubai it
was it's really hot in Dubai guys oh my
gosh it's it's so hot so humid you walk
like for a quarter mile and you're
drenched in sweat in Houston worse than
Houston definitely like so bad yeah yeah
yeah can i cambodia it's like it was so
bad that during the summer everyone just
like left everyone left for as long as
they could during the summers because it
was just very very odd that people leave
their houses air-conditioned while they
are gone I don't like part partly or I
wonder like if you didn't climate
control your house I'd have to ask my
parents cuz I wasn't aware of like air
conditioning logistics when I was six
but yeah we just left cuz in the summer
it was so bad and like the main activity
that people did outside was yeah
that way you got into swimming yeah
that's why I got in swimming well also
my mom was an instructor and I had been
swimming I've been spending my whole
I'm still swimming right now through
very very green waters because green
screen yeah but we I didn't I don't
actually have that many memories of
playing outside lots of lots of sports
and I did play sports outside like
soccer baseball basketball all of that
but a lot of swimming yeah so one
question that I looked up online that is
kind of lame but I'm still curious have
you always been like such a like serious
and dedicated student oh yes always
until like like the very end of senior
year of college
where I was like you know it's okay if I
get a B+ instead of a plus like all that
slide I already have a job I'll let it
slide they're like core personality
identifying thing it's like good student
oh yeah but not not just like A's like
if it was under a 95 I was disappointed
mm-hm cuz that 94 was like a - I was
always like somewhat serious about
school and it was a kind of priority for
me but I always kind of also just
breezed by and didn't take everything
super serious there was no breathing
there was no breathing I mean I I was
really good about not procrastinating so
I I didn't I mean I stressed but I would
have stressed a lot more if I like had
that pressure and I procrastinated he's
really gonna not procrastinating so I
was the worst I procrastinated so much
oh I know I know and I was such - the
opposite that like when I got to college
my friends would tease me because I'd be
like finishing a paper a month afore it
was due and they're like really I
haven't started [ __ ] I understand it now
and I probably would have even
understood the logistics of it at the
time it was just very hard for me to do
so I didn't do it yeah so what are some
of the things you liked and disliked
about school I mean I I liked learning
stuff some
times if I felt it was relevant to me I
hated memorizing stuff oh I hated
memorizing stuff I was the worst and
like depending on what age I was and
what school I was at I sometimes had a
good social experience and sometimes I
did not sometimes it was a positive
sometimes it was a negative well for me
it's like it was so interesting that
depending on the community I was in like
the the first day of school was like
great or really bad because when you
live overseas oftentimes in these
communities in these schools that you go
to you're surrounded by people who move
all the time so every year every
semester there's always new people
coming always new people leaving so
there's a system in place for that and
kids expect new kids yeah I mean when I
was little it didn't really matter yeah
cuz they're like oh new person hi
friends okay but then like by middle
school oh it was pretty tough especially
moving in the middle of the year yeah
seventh grade oh right in the middle of
seventh grade - that's the worst time to
move absolute worst that was in your
hooligan years that was at the end of my
hooligan years oh you would learned I
had learned yeah by going into the
hooligan school like that was actually
one of the good schools that like like
they you you you went to the office and
they had a student there that would show
you to your first class and introduced
you and have lunch with you and like it
was so great it was so magical because
like the whole thing was set up to
introduce you and get you going and get
you socially boosted right away and it
worked it worked it worked really well I
just fell in with the wrong crowd that
was I think moving to Texas it was like
the most awkward because when I moved
here everyone had known everyone for
their entire lives that wasn't awkward
for me too maybe Houston yeah yeah same
thing everyone in oh yeah well people in
Texas don't leave don't leave you know
blame because I don't really want to
leave Texas yeah yeah but it was yeah I
didn't know if it was because more
awkward because I was older or more
awkward because most people I knew had
had lived here their entire lives no
yeah it was
like a little bit more awkward moving
into a school in Houston because of like
yeah like by that point especially by
like end of middle school it's it's kind
of an awkward place to join in it's very
awkward alright and now a quick message
from our sponsors so it's actually a
perfect match for this like you know
partnering with Squarespace for the
podcast because we actually built a
website for this podcast I don't really
know what Squarespace is it's kind of a
one-stop shop for setting up your
website you can buy your domain there
you can get like everything set up all
the plugins are already there you don't
need to install anything third-party and
all the templates are already pre-built
to work with mobile and they're super
modern and nice-looking yeah and and
since it's all provided by a Squarespace
you don't need to worry about anything
third-party braking you don't need to
install any third-party like check out
app or anything like you have like a
shopping app built in with shipping and
all of that so which that specifically
is I think really cool because I know a
lot of people who listen to the podcast
are makers and y'all are often asking
you know for tips if you want to start
selling the stuff you make and I think
owning your own website is super super
powerful and with the Squarespace
product based websites there's no cap on
the amount of products you can sell
which i think is really cool they don't
cut you off at a certain number of
listings that's really crazy and if you
run into any troubles they have 24/7
support which is kind of a nice safety
blanket because websites are kind of
like they're a big deal big deal so go
to Squarespace calm for your free trial
and if you want 10% off go to
Squarespace calm /ev engagement podcasts
for Evan and Caitlin podcasts different
URL than the videos every column slash
evident getting podcasts do we know it
we nailed it back to it so what are some
of your most Awkward / embarrassing
stories oh geez
that's an awkward question to ask oh
yeah that is that the point of this
podcast there
like awkward The awkward years yeah okay
I'll give you my default stock answer
okay I shaved my entire body once well
you're in swimming
you ruined my punchline that's my fun
trying to give I guess like that crazy
stuff to your hair oh yeah yeah yeah so
like leading up to like the big swim
events like you know state or regionals
or something like that you know would
often shave our heads or like buzz it
down really like really short to like
reduce drag and it kind of increases the
feeling of the water on your skin and
makes you feel like you're faster it's
kind of like a placebo for making you
think that you're faster so you go
faster yeah and everything so before we
bust our hair would do crazy things so
it's like on the top of our heads would
like like carve in like a face or
something or would diet
I like bleached my tips once and then I
quickly shaved them off again because I
was horrible but we died our hair like
green and orange and just we just had
fun with it because we're gonna shave it
off soon after but that was like a
tradition we did that was really fun
that really wasn't that embarrassing I
remember when my mom and I convinced my
younger brother to let us bleach his
tips burned my bleaching burns your
scalp well it shouldn't if you're only
doing the tips it was like a whole bunch
of teenagers doing it that had no
experience there's a whole bunch of like
male teenagers messing with each other's
hair they had they had no they had we
had no experience it was very bad and it
showed
I think the probably the most
embarrassing story like for real is like
when I when I misbehaved and I wasn't a
good person it's not that's what I'm
like legit most embarrassed about that I
went through that phase in my life but
other than that I don't know
looking back I'm pretty embarrassed with
like my absolute lack of fashion sense
like oh my hair my outfits oh boy I have
but it was constantly changing every
time I moved and in a very extreme way
yeah I just didn't put much effort in
what would you wear I mean aside from
the alien t-shirts when you were younger
but like high school okay so like
specifically embarrassing things I had
like an embarrassing I'm not really
embarrassed of it like anymore or I
wasn't embarrassed at the moment but I
wonder if my parents were embarrassed
I'll chew on the front of my t-shirt
always I always like it was always kind
of like slightly warped and stop and
sometimes I'd get holes in it eight or
nine or seven there's something that was
in Dubai I just remember that in Dubai I
had some so when I was about that age
like I specifically remember my like
hand-picked outfit for the first day of
okay I don't remember if it's fourth
grade or fifth grade but was one of
those yeah
I'll describe it to you I had a lime
green t-shirt yeah with a white cat face
on it it was from limited to I had lime
green denim shorts yes like denim lime
green so the same lime green say Mayan
green head lime green tennis shoes and I
had lime green alien earrings oh that
was so all lime green except for a white
cat
oh I'm green yes that was my like first
first day of school outfit of choice
highlighter you're just you're just I
know it was good another of the another
favorite outfit of that same time period
as I had these velvet overalls mmm and
then I had a velvet t-shirt I would wear
with the velvet overalls and I had
velvet she was it was all either black
or dark red very nice good luck very
nice Hey fell that's coming back man you
know it's like such a memory trip when I
was thinking of like high school days
AOL Instant Messenger oh my gosh I have
so many feelings around like aim and
then like the noise it made when like
chats came in and like how many times
you'd like write something out then
delete it then write it and delete it
then like thing where you
going to like I figured it was call but
like invisible mode oh yeah totally so
like you could see who is on but you
know they couldn't see that you were and
then when someone that you want to talk
to joins you just casually come online
shortly after oh hey what's up yeah and
the completely awkward flirting that
happens on a just like like we didn't
ask each other for phone numbers you
would ask for like what's your name
screen name oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that
was like the thing so how awkward story
oh I was about to say like how smooth
were you at flirting are you tell
something embarrassing please do okay
please do okay it was like early high
school huh and there was this guy that
was in my gym class that I thought was
cute I did not know his name I had never
spoken to him
my only the only thing I knew is I was
like oh that guy's cute he didn't talk
he was very quiet and so lone wolf yes a
lone wolf I so one one day every now and
then like in PE we would have like a
study day where we didn't actually do
stuff we would all just go to the
cafeteria and study and it was kind of
like we would actually just all talk
yeah and so I was like you know what I'm
gonna be brave and I'm gonna go talk to
him I still don't know his name so I I
went up and I was like hey did I see you
at the Spurs game this weekend excuse
and he was like no wasn't me and I was
like oh ha ha and I I don't know how I
transitioned to this I blacked out but I
asked him for his his AOL like screen
name yeah I got it and then I chatted
him at some point really this is really
really boring ha ha it's not talkative I
thought so really the only story is
like my opening line oh yeah I see you
at the Spurs game last weekend build-up
to someone knowing full well that like
there is no I didn't see them total I
I'm gonna it's gonna be fully
transparent that I'm just lying here hey
that's really gutsy though r5 you thanks
high five to never did it again like
fifth grade you know no it was I was
like yeah pretty smooth one interesting
thing to think of after like sharing all
those embarrassing stories is like what
we are doing right now with their job
it's sharing our lives and like being in
front of the camera for millions of
people it's very public and we weren't
really centers of public attention no I
mean you guys heard the story from last
week about when I tried to like present
a commercial to class yeah not good at
it it's interesting though because
publicly I think that when we were
growing up we weren't ever really like
centers of attention but I think that at
home we did share a lot and we were both
kind of loud and interesting people like
it's always interesting that like your
parents always say that when when you're
back home it's like the the way louder
way louder yeah yeah it's like with
singing and random noises and like
everything like that so it's like at
home where we're comfortable that's
where we were able to express ourselves
and be weird and be loud and everything
but publicly it it wasn't really our
thing to be the center of attention and
in the strange way that still kind of
holds true I mean we're able to do this
very comfortably in front of you guys
partially because it's it's just the
camera yeah in a way yeah right the time
we're podcasting like we're in PJs from
the waist down
yeah another thing that's really
interesting is expanding it just not us
but one thing I notice is a lot of other
youtubers have a slight tendency towards
slight introversion and not being super
comfortable in front of huge crowds but
they're able to get there through the
videos that they have made build up that
confidence and like get through public
appearances until it still wears on oh
yeah I can definitely tell it wears a
lot cuz if you think about it like
someone who's doing YouTube full-time is
by themselves a lot more than the
average person who's working at a you
know either an office job or you know a
shift job either one of those you're
around other people and so much of the
job is also behind the computer like
setting up deals you know it's not
behind the computer even when you're
doing stuff in front of the camera it's
just you I mean for us is different cuz
two of us two of us yeah but like most
youtubers been probably more time alone
than the average person yeah cuz most
average people go to work and there's
people there most youtubers just are
like alone in their house with their
camera and talking to it that's really
interesting
yes I feel like it kind of makes sense
that a lot of us are kind of on the
introverted side yeah another thought
that I had when I was going through all
of the childhood stories and thinking
about what we wanted to talk about is
I'm kind of glad that we went through
that awkward Ugly Duckling type phase in
our life because I think it it let me
empathize with an even broader range of
people it let me be more empathetic in
general and
I'm kind of glad that I went through it
I still might be in that awkward ugly
duckling phase
I'm not saying I'm out of it I'm still
pretty awkward but um I don't know I'm
kind of glad that I went through that
phase in general yeah I mean I think I
think if you're in a place of comfort
all the time where you don't have to
push yourself you don't have to make new
friends you don't have to present
awkward commercials in front of the
class don't learn how to deal with those
situations when you're young and I feel
like it's a lot harder to deal with them
when you're older so I am grateful that
like we were in situations where we were
kind of awkward and out of place we
really it did help I'm still kind of
awkward and out of place well you know
what isn't awkward or out of place a
game a game
I'll just coffee you're trying to get
the timing right I've no I still don't
know the time that's alright with me
okay so I'm gonna pick up where we left
off on our game from last week which if
he missed last week at last week's
episode Pinterest releases an article of
trends every year based on the search
terms that are being searched so based
on what people are searching on
Pinterest that can tell you what things
are trending for that year so we're
going over 20 19 trends and she's
quizzing me cuz I'm an expert at
Pinterest trends such an expert okay um
so here's one in the home category it's
broken up by home by category so it's
like home travel food fashion etc so
here's one in the home category I'm
gonna read two answers of search terms
that are trending in 2019 and you're
gonna tell me which one is true and
which one is false
correct okay true okay so which of these
two things is trending having statement
ceilings or adding walls like the
opposite of open-concept
well it's really hard right now because
the the main place where I got fashion
advice for houses style advice is
fixer-upper and there is no like current
season the fixer-upper they're not
making them anymore they don't go as
much yeah I I know that adding like
statement ceilings was the thing I liked
the 10 ones and stuff you know like the
hammered some tiles yeah and I know that
people have been talking about adding
walls so it's like I know that both of
those are true things which means that
is really hard
you chose your diversion wisely yeah
sensei I don't know why I'm taking this
so seriously now I feel like I don't win
I want to win
I hope it's statement sealing this
because I think that's more fun than
adding walls but adding walls is I guess
kind of ease
if you think about the logistics of like
adding a wall versus removing the wall
because when you're adding the wall you
don't need to worry about structural
elements all you need to do is just like
put up some 2x4 or some drywall like
attach it into a stud and you're good to
go you know no big deal what would be a
situation where you might want to add a
wall if someone that had like made an
open-concept house went a little bit too
far you know so you add some like
dividers some like you know cuz walls
are important to like hang stuff on or
add like a little bit of division
between two areas to like delineate them
so it's like if I agree like I like that
our house is like semi open concept but
it's not just one giant big space I want
to say ceilings but I'm actually gonna
say adding walls final answer final
answer I talked myself out of it he was
so good searches are up three hundred
and ten percent but I do so the walls
thing that's not one you know some of
the answers in last episode that were
the false answers right yeah answers
from previous years that's not one but
it's one that I feel like I'm starting
to see like people rejecting open
concept open concept just a little bit
yeah like like it went super far on the
extreme or like every Home Makeover show
they would just literally take out every
wall from the main living space yep it's
an ad like beams and stuff yeah open
beams and their beams are so cool
yeah beans are so cool but like add
those like big massive beams to replace
the open-concept thing cuz like when you
when you take out walls you need to add
beams oh yeah yeah yeah yeah um so it is
interesting but I do see like I remember
in some of the later seasons a
fixer-upper every now and then they
didn't open it up as much or she has
added walls oh like partial walls that
are made of steel and glass and Marcie's
yeah yeah yeah I read that one yeah um
or like there was I feel like there's a
queer eye recently where they added a
wall so you know what my answer was just
the trends of 2020 yeah yeah so I'm just
like okay
okay I have one more home one for you oh
and I'll read I'll read what they said
about that statement ceilings um a
statement ceiling can transform a room
from the top down with bold paint
striking wallpaper or intricate texture
so I guess like the texture one that's
kind of like yes the oh no I think like
the tin oh the Tim I don't think they
mean like popcorn popcorn is making a
comeback no God no I have seen I so I've
seen like text texture as in like
ceiling tiles and like the tin tiles
I've seen bold colors I have not seen a
wallpaper I mean that would be kind of
weird though seems like a pain to add
yeah just like floppy paper roll falling
in your face seems terrible seems
terrible yeah anyways okay one more
home-related one not looking I'm okay
yeah don't look look at the camera okay
um so which item is trending ombre walls
or textile art textile art what's your
reasoning ombre walls seemed um also
like it seems like they'd be such a pain
to do like getting that fade correct and
everything I like and I just like
textiles more so I want that to be the
truth yeah huge increase 1718 percent
did you just make up the ombre walls no
that's actually is the thing it's not
from a past trend about ombre walls were
a thing for a bit and it did look really
difficult to do and it often looks bad
but sometimes it did look really cool
I'm sure I could look really cool if it
was done right like subtle I was like
subtle the good ones well it wasn't
about color like the two colors that
were fading from each other being subtle
it was about like how good their fade
was yeah I could see dividing layers it
wasn't good but some did get really good
so the two that I've seen good one was a
navy too white okay which I feel he was
in a bedroom or something but it looked
it looked cool like it was kind of like
a smoky fog so I classy colors too
classy colors the other one was
in a child's room and it was a blush to
white no I can see that as opposed to
like baby pink walls it was like a dusty
blush fade to like a creamy white I
think especially for like a smaller kids
room that that seems like appropriate
yeah it's kind of fun but it weren't
with the Navy also um yeah okay yeah
textile art so which is interesting
because I know my mom's been doing a lot
of that and we have some like textile
art from her in our house yeah and it's
like a it seems like it's a not super
intimidating thing to hop into yeah like
start start with yeah yeah do like stuff
yes okay I'm gonna go to another
category now men's style a point at
which I am a very expert on failure to
be a style consultant okay
so so which of these items is increasing
in search fanny packs oh yeah or sling
bags from men's fashion oh both both
does it just have both just have your
fanny pack and your sling bag but I
think fanny packs more do you know sling
bag is no it's like just like a like a
messenger bag but smaller not quite it's
like a fanny pack that goes around your
body weight no I'm doubting
I'm just staying a saying words that may
seem to make sense
Danny backs cuz I have one and I started
a trend it's like wow you should have no
twenty didn't know what a sling bag was
2020 I'm calling it fanny pack increase
I do I do agree with you I've been
seeing some fanny packs oh yeah a lot of
people are wearing on crossbody to you
yeah yeah yeah worried they wear it like
over the shoulder like a sash yeah I see
you like Julian doing a lot from 10 and
Julian yeah Julian does it yeah and he's
cool tremsetter
yeah and my mom got Evan a fanny pack
for Christmas it's neat it is nice
it is you can fit so much in there so
much in there yeah but so okay sling
bags up 1184 percent do you know why
they're called fanny packs why cuz they
sit on your fanny
no they're meant to go like originally
hi yeah that's that's how they're
designed they're designed to go like be
worn so they rest on your butt from the
front yeah okay but then like people did
it for travel and it's more convenient
and safer to have the zipper up front
yeah but it was originally intended to
be like resting on your booty oh I
didn't know that fanny pack and stuff on
the fanny yes 2020 mm-hmm okay here's
another one for in the men's style
category oh jeez
okay which one has an increased search
cropped trousers or jorts jorts are jean
shorts jeans yeah very hot right now so
hard I know what are cropped what's
cropped trousers what are those trousers
are kind of like slightly more
structured dance
I think cropped on the bottom or below
on top or below shorter like they're
cropped from the bottom like your ankles
show like capris for men no those are
called capris actually those are just be
shorts cuz your shorts are like the
length of a woman's capris cropped like
they show like a little ankle like this
much only enhance the fat 5 sometimes
wear it so like maybe they're in style
you don't sound confident yet do you
understand what each is I do now
understand what each is let's say
cropped things cropped jorts both okay
crops the crop things very bad never
yeah I think I've said that a few times
here yeah I thought I might throw in a
wild card with Jordans huh queer eye has
my back yep when their crops
yeah yeah they roll up other ones too
sleeves yep yes leaves to look I'm doing
that right just roll up every thermal
dude cap sleeve sorry for every line I'm
just listening to this it's really
interesting visuals look how cool yeah
okay are you ready for women's style I'm
ready okay because I also read read the
articles about women's style yeah I mean
you got to stay up-to-date on everything
if you're a trendsetter okay as I am
okay which one had the which one had the
higher search terms tortoise earrings or
celebrity airport style our tortoise
earrings earrings that are of tortoises
I have no information for you there
I would assume tortoise shell because my
guess is earrings with little turtles on
Celebrity Airport fashions nope
Wow what I thought I was too random to
be made up it's a 20-17 trend what it
just seems weird to me I put that one in
there cuz I was like who's who's
thinking to search celebrity Airport
style
yeah just dressed up for the airport
what people do video
yeah people I mean some people who are
going on business and then like full
comfy yeah but back in the day it was
like a luxury to travel by air the same
way was like a luxury to travel by train
like you had to you know be able to
afford that mm-hmm and so you would get
dressed up for it I think I was not
alive
all right was very little I don't know I
don't know what time period I'm just
gonna stop talking okay but so I could
see how someone could look at a look and
be like yeah that's kind of like
celebrity Airport chic but I don't like
as myself think to search celebrity
Airport style yeah it's like in a way as
a celebrity you're always in like public
your ear exposed Republican who knows
when someone's gonna take a photo of you
yeah so you're like always under
pressure to look at least somewhat good
but like you probably also want to be
kind of comfy yeah yeah yeah I think it
is you know I'm kind of down with that
but that should be my fancy normal fancy
yeah but so so for the tortoise I the
tortoise earrings it just says it was
not very clear whether or not it was
little turtle more like tortoise shell
pattern stuff I'm assuming it's like
tortoise shell you know like
tortoiseshell glasses like big round
thing it's like a pattern on the frames
it's kind of like dark brown and lighter
brown kind of modeled okay okay you know
a picture a picture like the way light
looks and shadows like when it's going
through the leaves of a tree okay yeah
model modeled and there are two
different shades of brown kind of like a
Goldy in a dark brown that's like
tortoiseshell okay softening glasses are
like hair clips and stuff so I'm
thinking it's that but the the
description just says up your shell game
hares beware slow and steady wins the
race with these versatile sophisticated
tortoise earrings doesn't say tortoise
shell earrings it just says tortoise
earrings
good job Pinterest are their tiny
Turtles
so I get some that match my tiny aliens
from fifth grade yes Lisa Frank style
neon neon okay I have another woman's so
which one got more search terms bamboo
bags or berets bamboo backs number one I
totally know it finally you don't like
Berets no I just know bamboo bags are
like a thing yeah it's it's huge
thousand two thousand two hundred
fifteen percent increase from last
bamboo bags that's like a thing it's you
know super environmental and
environmental things are like sniper
from the bamboo bamboo is just like I
know that bamboo in general is very
environmentally friendly but I I don't
know how its translated to bags I mainly
know of it in terms of like like bamboo
flooring or bamboo I'm just super trendy
and I keep up with the trends look at
these rolled sleeves if you're watching
the video if not just imagine
um yeah yeah it says stay connected to
nature by carrying all the essentials in
a striking structured handbag I mean
that doesn't you could say that about
any striking structured handbag it
doesn't have to be bamboo but yeah I
just wasn't really sure how they were
made I think this is a trendy material
okay but berets berets was up last year
that's cause of Heineman yeah he was
really trending in 2018 really chanting
there was some random celebrity that
wore a beret everyone crazy yeah I'm
sure other people know who that person
is I don't okay I have one more category
two more questions so this is the Beauty
category which is fitting because guru
drama lately
boobity okay so which which is trending
almond nails or avocado nails I'm
guessing they're like dips that you dip
it in or like ways to treat it or are
they like nails like like nail art
you're just gonna have to use your best
judgment avocados are always trendy true
almonds are pretty trendy too though
it's avocado I've always because like
how you reacted do you know always
trendy okay so it's almond nails and
it's about the shape Oh like the shape
of the nail shaping them like almonds
where it's like kind of like a rounded
point at the end okay being like a
rounded tip r-squared tip it's like a
rounded point tip oh yeah weird right
weird okay like scratchy noise yeah but
you know what's so fake too
is it could have been avocados - because
almonds and avocados have the same shape
so I
technically correct a little bit no same
shape like nude lashes or glossy makeup
nude lashes they're their minimal lashes
they they're they're nude they have
genitalia on them you're gonna say like
they they're it's like people not
wearing anything on their lashes that's
it like it's like a nude colored mascara
you know be really weird yeah if you put
like skin colored mascara on your
eyelashes that this major eyelashes
completely disappear white mascara is a
thing that some people do yeah it would
that would disappear I'm nice what pale
is too strong nude nude lashes no so
nude lashes I didn't really know what I
thought you would think one it just
sounded like two beauty words that I
could put together but glossy makeup is
it's a nude lashes isn't even the real
thing no I just made it oh dang it
chosen which I know yeah yeah and that's
where it like you do like a skin colored
color on your lips so here let the
others disappear yeah that's creepy nude
lips
I mean well they don't actually
disappear fully like there's different
levels of nude like what if you like
perfectly matched like and then like
with your babies and then stuff because
sometimes people you can see what that
looks like because a lot of hims the
booty gurus will put foundation over
their lips first yeah so there's like a
completely flat face like an egg yeah
yeah yeah so you can see what that looks
like it looks weird very strange but so
so glossy makeup
it says gloss is helping
people's best features shine from lips
to lids
is that just like highlighter I don't
think so because like contouring glass
implies shiny the quiddity yeah and I
have seen like liquid highlighters and
there is liquid eyeshadow and I've tried
I think if it's high gloss on makeup
that just looks weird on your face it
just I mean I could kind of see it for
like a highlighter but for eyes oh my
god I just imagine it sliding everywhere
nothing hoop it's not gonna stay put
imagine having something like lik a
liquidy cream on your eyelids how is
that not gonna move around when you
blink or if you sweat it all yes those
bootie gurus love that harsh life that
harsh life there's no sweating no
avoiding no blinking and constantly
being sticky
[Laughter]
okay well that ends my my trend things
that I got it well what what grade did
they get teacher fifty half right glass
half 50-50 shot yeah I was pretty much
guessing on everyone yes thank you
that's interesting and I think you are
right about some of the 2020 trends like
fanny packs yeah and what was the other
one
jorts I'm just a head of my friend all
right so things of the week
[Music]
so my thing of the week is a channel
it's a whole channel called creator
insider it's a whole bunch of people at
YouTube that just want to get more
information out it's not Shane
sanctioned by YouTube there's not like
an official YouTube channel but YouTube
allows this employees to do it they
don't like it's not part of their job
descriptions it's just like people
trying to get more information out and I
really respect that if you have a
youtube channel it's it's often the
channel that shows up in your dashboard
yeah little tips videos and stuff yeah
and they just give like tips on like new
experiments they're trying where they
you know are trying like a new UI or
they added a new feature or you know
updates about back end things that are
going on that affect so many people and
I really appreciate them putting that
time in so I thought everyone listening
is necessarily doing YouTube stuff but
if it's something you're considering or
that you have started doing it's
definitely a really good thing to look
into truth yeah okay my turn your turn
okay my turn is one of my favorite
podcasts that I hope I haven't given as
my thing of the week hi Google search it
with our own like in our own system and
it didn't show up okay cool cuz I've
recommended this to a lot of people so I
don't know okay it's a podcast called
ologies the host is Ali Ward we first
discovered it when Simone yesh was on it
yeah his mala G episode but basically
Ali interviews different ologists and so
it's a different topic every single week
it's like a huge range like the last few
I've listened to were glued ology which
is the study of video games hagfish
ology which is the study of hagfish and
then what was about like fear the fear
one was really good was like a
two-parter ooh so good so good the
beauty standards one was really good
yeah we just learned a lot about life
and the world and all sorts of things
and the people she brings on are so
passionate for what they do
yeah so interesting so interesting and
and and even if you think that you're
not interested in that topic listen to
it and you'll get something from it I
didn't think I was gonna be inches
hagfish I didn't know what hagfish was I
had to google it after this cuz I was so
interested in like seeing what they
looked like
after talking about them so much do you
know what a heck fishes they're slimy
and that's gross that's all I know
you slimy they're like slimy so Allie
described them as slimy little hot dogs
with eyes oh yeah that's Mary Mary whew
off but like Allie is hilarious as I
love the podcast when she's so good at
any of you young people she does a lot
of research beforehand she asks the
right questions and she does also has
fun with it yeah she's super so much fun
yeah yeah we'll link to those things if
you need more podcasts that's that
that's a good shoutout for us yeah words
are hard yeah I think it's about time to
end the words yeah I think you guys so
much for tuning in for this week's
episode I hope it was enjoyable if you
have more suggestions for different
pop-pop-pop-pop casts for different
topics we can cover in the future head
over to youtube.com slash Evan Caitlin
go over to the community tab and leave
some comments there pumping up both the
ones that you want so that they raised
to the top and we'll look forward to
seeing in the next one
[Music]